our rent was going up and my husband and
I decided okay let's go ahead and move
into an RV well I already had one that
was paid off I traded that in and we
purchased one and so that's what we're
doing right now is we we have a brand
new RV and we pay space rent so that's
our housing we needed upgrade truck for
the RV anyway and so we went ahead and
made uh a purchase for a a truck to pull
the RV we oh
56623 on it right now 56,000 hold hold
did you say you bought a truck for for
56,000 yes it was a
2021 um F250 diesel for 58,000 it was a
deal it was a great deal the payment is
uh 946 and some change W and we had to
yeah it's nut wait no wait hold on hold
on hold on I got to call you out first
you said it was a great deal then you
just now turn around and said it's nuts
and just for the record payment yeah it
is nuts